[Applaudissements]
et si l'entreprise disparaissait alors
attendez excusez moi je ne va pas parler
un truc pareil au sein d'une des plus
grandes entreprises au monde et devant
des gens dont probablement 80 % des
revenus dépendent de l'entreprise et
excusez moi enfin avec un blizzard
stylet et si l'entreprise disparaît
c'est quand je lui ai également un peu
intrigué je les trouve un peu absurde
mais j'ai décidé de la suivre pour
savoir où est-ce qu'elle allait
m'emmener helmand mené là une maison
quoi de plus banal
est ce que c'est vraiment une maison où
est-ce que c'est seulement une maison
c'est peut-être aussi un hôtel avec
airbnb c'est peut-être aussi une
entreprise de transport c'est peut-être
aussi un parking
c'est peut-être aussi une ferme et
pourquoi pas un terrain de camping ou un
restaurant ou laverie automatique ou
bien un entrepôt de stockage peut-être
ou alors un magasin ou une banque vous
rajoutez une imprimante 3d dans le
garage et vous avez une usine vous
rajoutez des panneaux solaires sur le
toit
vous avez une centrale électrique c'est
pas une maison c'est toute l'économie du
monde
ce petit capital mon micro capitale
il devient productif et moi je deviens
un micro capitaliste alors je vais me
battre contre des vrais capitaliste
c'est vrai capitaliste ils ont des
trains ils ont des hôtels ils ont plein
de structures je vais me faire laminer
c'est pas possible
mais regardez mon micro compte de
résultat
j'ai pas d'amortissement j'ai amorti par
mon capital j'ai pas de salaire
j'ai pas de cotisations sociales j'ai
une marque qui est gratuite parce
qu'elle est faite par les clients
donnent des étoiles
cette marque là figurez vous qu'elle est
plus reconnu que les marques soutenu par
des millions de dépenses en marketing
j'ai un accès au marché
par la plateforme qui n'est pas cher du
tout donc en jeu proposant blaquart un
paris-lyon je suis à 25 euros
la sncf est à 71 euros le micro
capitaliste et plus compétitif que le
capitaliste alors vous allez me dire est
toujours des entreprises les plateformes
c'est des entreprises oh mais où sont
les salariés dans l'industrie hôtelière
en france vous avez besoin de 300
salariés pour gérer 1000 chambres cher
bienne be pour jérémy l'hébergement vous
avez besoin d'un salarié un seul le
travail disparaît pas mais il est
transféré au micro capitalisme et aux
individus qui vont faire l'accueil de la
personne qui vont lui donner les clés
qui vont les bergers qui vont faire la
chambre donc le micro capitalisme
transfert du travail du salariat vers le
nom saharien on peut même aller un cran
plus loin encore est ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'entreprises pour faire les
plateformes
imaginez lenovo de garage vous avez vos
petits robots qui fabrique une voiture
quelque chose qui ressemble à ça et puis
vous allez ensuite quand elle sera
fabriquée la mettre sur une plate-forme
en pair à pair sur un réseau sécurisé un
blog shane qui va permettre aux gens de
prendre cette voiture-là d'être
transportés de payer et vous allez en
retirer des revenus
ça vous paraît complètement fumiste
utopique il ya aujourd'hui une
entreprise française qui s'appelle mobo
tic outils en train de développer ce
modèle économique et qui veut mettre en
circulation à paris 4000 véhicules avant
les jeux olympiques de 2024
aujourd'hui ce type de modèle là je sais
pas si ça va marcher
je sais pas quand ça a marché mais ils
sont déjà en train de réinventer le
capitalisme alors ça c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
ou c'est plutôt une mauvaise nouvelle je
posais la question autrement
qui parmi vous a envie d'être hub et
reese est hélas ce n'est pas ta part
fait pas tout à fait pareil quand même
pourtant ça devrait être une bonne
nouvelle c'est une formidable
opportunité de revenir locale avant on
allait à l' usine aujourd'hui celle
usine qui vient à nous avant on allait
au bureau aujourd'hui avec une connexion
haut débit
et en voiture une voiture autonome on
peut parfaitement travaillé de la houve
avant les personnes quitter la campagne
pour aller travailler dans les vignes
dans les endroits pollués avec beaucoup
de temps de transport demain on pourra
éviter ces temps de transport on pourra
retisser du lien social là où on a envie
de vivre et non pas là où on doit
travailler c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
pourtant nous avons peur pourquoi nous
avons peur c'est quand même pas le
salariat qui aussi merveilleux que ça
marx ne visaient bien le salariat c'est
l'exploitation du travailleur c'est du
vol
il voulait abolir le salariat tout le
cinéma au xxème siècle nous explique que
le salariat c'est l'aliénation de la
personne le cabinet mckinsey a fait une
étude l'année dernière ils ont interrogé
huit mille personnes des salariés et les
indépendants
ils leur ont dit est ce que vous êtes
plutôt plus heureux ou moins heureux sur
un certain nombre de critères 15
critères sur treize des quinze critères
les indépendants étaient plus heureux
que les salariés sur l'autonomie sur la
liberté sur le temps de travail sur les
revenus sur la capacité à apprendre
beaucoup plus heureux marx et
maquilleuses et sont d'accord
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a peur mais en
fait c'est quoi les deux critères sur
lesquels les salariés étaient plus
heureux que les indépendants c'est la
sécurité
et ce à la protection sociale et c'est
pour ça qu'on a peur parce que tout
notre système il est fondé sur
l'entreprise
les cotisations financent notre
protection sociale
il finance notre retraite notre
assurance chômage
notre santé les allocations familiales
c'est l'entreprise qui s'occupe de notre
formation c'est l'entreprise qui
s'assure qu'on a un minimum pour vivre à
travers leur salaire minimum et même
pour le logement
si vous n'avez pas vos trois fiches de
paye consécutive du même employeur vous
ne trouvez pas le logement tout notre
système est fondé sur l'entreprise et si
l'entreprise recul si elle disparaît le
système s'effondre mais au fond est ce
qu'on a besoin de l'entreprise on a
besoin de créer de la richesse oui on a
besoin de l'activité économique pour
créer de la richesse
mais si cette richesse est créée et
qu'on arrive à la redistribuer on n'a
pas vraiment dans l'entreprise alors
aussi cette social il ressemble un peu à
ça on en est très fier on trouve qu'il
est super mais quand même il a été fondé
dans les années 40 45
il ya soixante dix ans et il commence un
peu à faire son âge l'idée c'est
peut-être qu'on pourrait le déconstruire
garder les briques mais reconstruire
quelque chose de complètement nouveau
en disant je ne le centre pas sur
l'entreprise je le sens sur la personne
alors ça pourrait donner quelque chose
comme ça c'est quand même plus
sympathique
donc je vous propose de faire un petit
travail d'essayer de faire ça ensemble
de se dire voilà fonds dont un nouveau
pacte social ensemble
alors à partir de notre devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
notre pacte commun on va voir ce que ça
peut donner pour refonder une protection
sociale liberté c'est la possibilité
qu'on a tous individuellement de rentrer
dans l'activité économique et de faire
ce qu'on a envie de faire sans qu'ils
aient des barrières artificielles sans
que nous empêche de le faire donc on
arrête d'essayer de protéger des
procédés des professions installe
et on libéralise le marché oui mais en
même temps égalité il faut que si je le
dois être compétitif sur ce marché quand
je rentre en concurrence avec des
entreprises il faut que ce soit à armes
égales
ça veut dire notamment que la fiscalité
des revenus des particuliers et des
entreprises
dans ce modèle là doit converger on doit
avoir une fiscalité commune une
imposition commune sur le revenu et non
pas la foultitude d'impôts qu'on a
aujourd'hui
fraternité le plus important peut-être
c'est quoi le socle commun de solidarité
autour duquel on se met d'accord
alors bien sûr il ya la santé la santé
pour tous de manière universelle
bien sûr il ya l'éducation mais pas
jusqu'à 18 ou 25 ans jusqu'à 70 ans
demain on aura besoin de se former tout
au long de notre vie et pas forcément
avec l'entreprise aujourd'hui si vous
prenez les 22 milliards de budget de
formation professionnelle vous pouvez
les transformer en un chèque de 800
euros par personne et par an à la
discrétion de la personne pour qu'elle
puisse se former et puis peut-être un
troisième bloc important qui le revenu
minimum le revenu socle n'ont pas un
revenu pour arrêter de travailler
mais un revenu pour construire un revenu
de base sur lesquelles on pourrait
construire un projet de vie aujourd'hui
500 euros c'est à peu près ce qu'on
pourrait se permettre comme revenu de
base ou revenus socle 500 euros c'est ce
que dépense l'état aujourd'hui pour
toutes les personnes qui sont dans la
précarité soit sous la forme du rsa soit
sous la forme de réduction fillon soit
sous la forme d emplois aidés soit sous
la forme du régime des intermittents du
spectacle plein de formes différentes
mais c'est toujours à peu près le même
montant 5 à 600 euros et c'est le
montant que pourrait organiser en un
revenu qui serait distribué à tout le
monde qu'on commencerait à rembourser
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
ses revenus augmentent jusqu'à ce qu'il
soit entre entièrement remboursés pour
les revenus aisés aujourd'hui c'est
faisable dans l'enveloppé actuelle en
information ses ingénieurs
j'ai été aussi au bcg et quand je
raconte quelque chose j'aime bien
vérifier si c'est possible et donc j'ai
travaillé sur dix mille foyers fiscaux
dix mille ménages représentatifs de la
population française pour regarder si ça
vous plaît effectivement j'ai calculé
les paramètres qu'il fallait pour que ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui ce type de
systèmes l'un est accessible
alors je ne sais pas si une entreprise
va disparaître en revanche je sais c'est
que ce serait dommage que pas construire
une protection sociale universel pour
nous et pour nos enfants qu'ils soient
construites autour de la personne et non
pas de l'entreprise et quand j'ai
commencé à travailler sur ce sujet là
les premières idées que j'ai eue ils
m'ont semblé absurde
elles m'ont semblé délirante et puis je
les ai écoutés et elles sont devenues
elles m'ont convaincu elles sont
devenues le coeur de mon argumentation
et c'est peut-être ça que j'ai envie de
vous dire ce soir si vous entendez des
idées absurdes
écoutez les au 19e siècle
ces idées absurdes elle s'appelait
éducation gratuite et obligatoire
elle s'appelait retraite elle s'appelait
assurance chômage
elle s'appelait abolition de la peine de
mort elle était absurde quand elles ont
été vite
aujourd'hui c'est le coeur de notre
modèle demain les idées absurdes
c'est le micro capitalisme c'est le
revenu universel salamone hélicoptère
c'est sur ces idées là que nous allons
construire le monde de demain à une
seule condition qu'on les écoute
je remercie
[Applaudissements]